[Music]
in weird flex news submitted by
beastmode wow this is fitness [ __ ] a man
who was arrested after admitting he ate
a woman's pet fish even close that was
an Asian person
end of story next article oh it's not no
Chinese first doesn't like that you say
at first before I tell my pet it made my
pet fish eating story Maya I had an ex
in my early 20s and we're friends now
but he we had gotten into a pretty bad
tiff at that time his name is Matt Matt
yeah Matt he's a he's a great guy I love
him on his way out to spite me I had a
turtle named Otis and he was a red-eared
slider and we would feed Otis fish but
there was one fish he refused to eat and
his name was Milford and Milford and
Otis were best friends no matter how
many fish I put in there Otis would
never eat Milford it's a love story so
yes a little story and so he knew that I
had a very special place in my heart for
Milford
so to spite me on his way out of my
apartment he took a cup and he swallowed
Milford what the [ __ ]
sunk into a depression for a long time
Milford your ex-boyfriend a dirty turtle
water Salmonella well I was hoping that
he would get salmonella but he didn't
all that ever had God you know that ever
happened from guys of Milford vibe I
guarantee you that pool had explosive
diarrhea he just refuses to tell jungle
man that's what you get out of the
[ __ ] story you [ __ ] animal no but
it's true
Milford died Milford I acknowledge it
might be a David what would you send 1l
a dieter say those stories can you not
smile then because it's confusing he's
trying to wish the worst upon the person
that killed your kid I'm just curious
he was hoping that he would have a
deadly disease
yeah so he's dad I was hoping that he
would had that's his act of revenge at
that time we were like 20 years old we
were just probably angry more cuz that's
like the equivalent of him going out he
saw your cat and he breaks the cat's
back and he walks out oh yeah
friends with that [ __ ] yeah he's 20
years 30 he's been in my house he's been
in my house this guy man his kids
I love his wife like it's we're actually
a very much you care about his kids I'm
the godmother there is a photo on the
refrigerator with Matt and his wife and
his children we were very close well
[ __ ] his kids and we talk about this
variance were created from the nutrients
from one of its [ __ ] you kids need
Milford hop yeah Mel or milf
yeah it's his [ __ ] wife a milk
there's some relation in there I believe
yes what's your dog's name
let me ask you a question okay if I came
to your house you know I walk in your
house your little baby your babies are
all right whatever right and that you
have another dog with your other dogs
and only one to find and meatloaf Vaughn
and meatloaf right I would have on I
hope to me booboo put you in pump right
and I went to meet love but I just broke
his paw why did chattered his bones in
his hand it's impossible you think the
hundred pounds you'd kill you napped I
put the little poison in his mouth
he's not your dad he's knocked out and I
break his ankle or his paw and I go
bye-bye
would you what would you do I'd shoot
you in the back of the head as you're
walking away you wouldn't move yeah
really yeah I love my dog I hardly I
didn't kill him but I hardly know you
and you just harmed my family you have
to kill Bobby you just have to break his
hurt me so bad right now little right
kind hardly know you and [ __ ] and then
she said no nerf was like five years I
hardly know you called me Gina and Ghani
and Donnie boy and go yeah okay and
that's where we're at we got a little
too soon that's why I brought up that
scenario I don't want to see where we
were at yeah you know nothing yes what
would you do if she did that to your cat
yeah people might think a cat's paw I
grabbed her violently where where would
you grab me by the neck are you here if
he was a regular part spot around let me
talk to you for a second I bet you Bart
would just be watching to right until
the point where G is almost about to die
I will go like difficult yeah cuz he
always wants to see what I'm made of so
he wants like he wants me to get pushed
to like the [ __ ] corner and then see
how many I see though Gio you could take
Bobby I'm pretty sure yeah I think hey
hey I have my money on you dude let's do
it right now let's move the chairs oh no
no no your mom I only say this because
the last time I saw him he was trying to
grab my penis and I was earnestly trying
to get him to stop he still grabbed it I
don't know if you're a good example
though true that's highly-trained
bullets going directions I think so what
scenarios this hey what scenario is this
am I am I am I in my house or a weird
your house it does matter
let me explain you pick the house fine
we're at tips awesome Tony me which
floor okay not which lords's and we're
talking about the cat's where the cat
right next to you next to you I'm
holding him like this so I'm like yeah
[ __ ]
okay cool what was I doing play piano
are we
movie we're writing together what good
that's the question what song easy
poisoner the la-la-land song the
la-la-land song where's Casey at this
moment cooking but seriously in a
scenario where this was like The Hunger
Games and we had to kill each other
oh dude and there was only one person
that was gonna survive with me the first
one to die we would get together well
overthrow the [ __ ] that put us
in here you could get some weapons each
other
forget the Hunger Games and this is like
what's the other one that the Japanese
right join up at the end you two people
joined up at then maybe those movies who
would die / WWE Royal Rumble yeah who
would die for us I think kalila would
divers because if your anxiety David
yeah put you in that room and lock the
door in the national fight or flight
response is always on that's what
anxiety is I have a my fight-or-flight
response is inappropriate to my
situation what it means is that I'm
primed for action you see that spit fly
your direction
I'm priming she's prefer I've always
turned on ya if I had to [ __ ] Sprint
ID sprint right the [ __ ] now so my
anxiety is actually an advantage yeah I
didn't listen to anything that you said
I completely blanked out but I I believe
you survival mode you're actually very
laser focus I agree you would survive
the most could because you keep talking
we shoot myself in the face what the
[ __ ] you're saying sorry tell this nice
22 year old man is facing charges of
cruelty to animals and proper telephone
communications and fugitive armed
justice wait what is he what would from
justice sorry it was the article
man arrested after admitting he ate a
woman's pet fish Oh Ella Bache plays at
Louisiana State University LSU the
victim she had allowed her ex-boyfriend
and some friends to stay in her dorm for
a game they all hurt
Paden tailgating events and stuff when
she returned back to her room the next
day she let one of the men named Maxwell
that's not come in and collect some of
his belongings from her room and at that
time he told her oh by the way check
your fish tank and then he ran out of
the room and then she looked at the fish
tank there was no fish inside the tank
and then later he sent her a photo of
[ __ ] in the toilet with the caption
found her fish and then so she went to
the police so for no reason at all like
no motives that's all they tell me so
I'm pretty sure there's more to the
story and I wasn't reporter rejected man
that's a guy that's a guy oh he looks
like a fish eater look and see this you
know what makes him crazy his eyes he's
pupil to white ratio and his eyes are so
close together Wow he's like a white Joe
look at that eye that's true yeah yeah
he is kind of good eyebrows Krita for
being a criminal right yeah oh he does
look like an owl it's like Connery son
or something he looks like an eye yeah
thank you
why would he there was no reason why you
don't tell us in the article but I'm
gonna tell you what he should happen to
him he should be there should be charges
I don't need to go to prison that's the
animal cruelty it is animal appropriate
but he should have a fine and he should
what do you mean you explain that what's
animal cruelty when you're mean to
animals you punch a cat in the face if I
go to the beach and I feed dolphins
Leiter's guilty then you've given a
dolphin a lighter and 1/6 rose see
that's them
I was kidding me man yeah no I that what
he did was you know he there's something
else hidden underneath if you think that
that is okay that cycle if I first met
you you to fish in no matter if we got
in a fight or not or you couldn't called
me you Pantheon's could get or whatever
I still would never even think about
eating your [ __ ] fish that's cuz to
me that's another layup crazy serial
killer behavior
what's a Bobby Lee revenge tactic then
what like will give me the scenario for
me right let's say you and I are cousins
okay I came in one day you're playing
Red Dead Redemption and I [ __ ]
smashed your [ __ ] while you're doing
some kind of crazy [ __ ] so I'm playing
red jet you smashed my [ __ ] xbox
yup wah-wah-wah-wah-wah and then I was
like April Fool's
but it's March okay then we'll you know
what I would do yeah is exactly what I
would do okay okay
I go to Best Buy mm-hmm and buy another
one I tell your mom that's it yeah
that's not what you know I wouldn't do
the plugs in her room all right so if
you turn the light on and off if you
turn it off his system goes down to
wrong turn it off once by accident Jim
with died I almost died what did you do
I taped it yeah you can't turn it off
anymore he put like [ __ ] it's a good
move yeah yeah relative Grillet okay
yeah yeah now if you actually did that
to me I would arm I would call you and
go why'd you do that bro okay okay so
this is what I do dude um yeah I'm gonna
I'm doing everything in my power that
you're never gonna be around me again
okay
what are you doing at house cuz I'm
family oh you're my cousin that's right
yeah okay well bully cousin don't do it
again then
[Music]